now at this point the White House needs
to hire some professional writers I
think because they're running out of
good lines the growing trail of evidence
leading to the Biden family to their
corruption to the special treatment they
received along the way it's getting
harder and harder to explain
this is a hunter Biden as you know is a
private citizen and this was done in an
independent way the Department of
Justice is independent we give them the
space to be independent and we respect a
rule of law
she did stand up now the details of the
now defunct Hunter Biden plea show once
again how far the legal system will bend
to accommodate and ultimately protect
the bidens so the rule of law is always
an after thought for these people what's
important is keeping Joe Biden in power
so after combing through both the plea
agreement itself as well as the
transcript of yesterday's Court
proceedings the angle understands why
there was such a concerted effort to
keep it all from the public now the most
damning provision and when we hit
briefly last night would have granted
absurdly broad immunity to Hunter Biden
very conveniently it would have covered
every crime he may have committed during
the relevant time frame presumably
stuff regarding his lucrative business
dealings with foreign entities based in
China Romania Ukraine and God knows
where else
now the effort to Shield hunter from
further investigations this is an
explosive development and it begs the
question
if all these relationships he had with
foreign business interests were on the
up and up
now why would the first son and why
would his legal team think he needed
this expansive immunity deal
and why wasn't this known until
yesterday well I'll tell you why because
it appears that the lawyers from Joe
Biden's doj and Hunter's legal team were
in cahoots
the secret get out of jail free
Arrangement was hidden in paragraph 15
of something called the pre-trial
diversion agreement not even the deal
itself so when judge norika discovered
the scope of the immunity and then the
unconstitutional role it would have
conferred upon her she was not happy
this from Judge nareka what's funny to
me is that you put me smack dab in the
middle of the diversion agreement that I
should have no role in you just take it
out and you say your honor don't pay any
attention to that provision not to
prosecute because we put it in the
agreement that's beyond your ability
well I saw weisenberg will be here in
just a few moments points out this is
totally unprecedented in fact judge
narica asked Biden's justice department
cronies five times was there any
precedent is there any precedent for
such a one-sided plea agreement with
this broad immunity like the one that
they gave Hunter so she said do you have
any precedent for agreeing not to
prosecute crimes that have nothing to do
with this case or the charges being
diverted
the federal prosecutor Leah wise
responded I am not aware of any your
honor
other times upon further questioning he
replied that there was no precedent
finally adding this was crafted to suit
the facts and circumstances
facts and circumstances is that legalese
for never before done type of plea deal
for the son of a sitting president
well naturally axios reports that the
hunter Biden the legal team is angry and
judge narika for deliberately
questioning lawyers on both sides about
the terms of the deal now imagine a
judge being curious about how this all
went down
doing her job maybe
but that's not all that's not allowed
according to Biden's Gatekeepers is it
unusual for a judge not to accept a plea
deal like this because it felt kind of
surprising to everybody watching it I
don't think that some of the comments
that I read that the judge made needed
to be provided and quite sort of the
provocative way in which they were
provided of course this judge is a
political appointee and a republican
when the judge is Trump appointed it
just doesn't fall on any kind of reality
a political appointee yes judges are
appointed by President sweetheart nice
going
well the obvious question here is what
were all these lawyers trying to hide
not not the judge's comments in court
One exchange from the transcript that
might help tell this story is when the
judge asked so there are references to
foreign companies for example in the
facts section
could the government bring a charge
under the foreign agent's registration
Act
Mr wise then answers yes
here's Jonathan Turley explaining why
that matters
because the judge just raised the one
charge that the White House most fears
which is the chance that Hunter was a
foreign agent and if he was a foreign
agent the question is for an agent for
who and for what purpose the president
was that purpose if your influence
peddling its influence over the
president
and there it is given what Senate and
House investigators are uncovering it
seems like on a weekly basis now is
there any doubt that that is what was
driving all the subterfuge here
the actions of Hunter's lawyers are
almost understandable I guess they're
representing Hunter Biden of course
they're trying to get the best deal for
their client
but the actions taken by the doj those
are an insult to every law-abiding
citizen in this country
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else